one of televisions most popular dramas
is coming to an end the final episode of
Showtime's hit series homeland will air
this Sunday single-tier for me
actor Mandy Patinkin has played CIA
agent turned national security adviser
Saul Berenson for nearly a decade in
this clip from the series finale Saul
confronts his protege you know that's
Carrie Mathison about her recent
behavior she is played by the great
actress Claire Danes starting with why
you haven't checked in on Franny since
you've been back so I'm going to of
course I am I've been busy
too busy to see your own daughter I was
waiting until the weekend it's cuz you
don't want to think about ever all over
again truth is you're not planning on
staying in the country very long are you
which begs the question why come back at
all I came back to try and stop a war
stop war I plan to do that stop a war
any way I can
Showtime is a division of Viacom CBS and
Mandy Patinkin joins us now from his
home in upstate New York
good morning to you Mandy I want the
viewers to know you're also a prop
stylist because right before you went on
the air you said want me to put some
tape on that window and tape it up for
you we thank you that you're so you
notice those kind of things I thought
that was nice want me to get some duct
tape so Mandy let's talk about good
no I decide any gaffers tape wherever I
go I got plenty of gaffers tape wherever
I go yeah duct tape will solve anything
but let's talk about the series finale
number one I know you're not gonna tell
us anything about that so I'm not gonna
ask you that but I will ask you this are
you pleased with how the series wrapped
up because Monday morning there will be
a lot of quarterbacking about they
should have done that why did they do
that what happened to her what happened
to him are you pleased with how the
series is wrapping up after eight
seasons you know I was very pleased I
thought that Alex Kahn's on the team
came up with a great ending and I don't
think people will be disappointed I
wasn't disappointed I thought it stayed
true to what the CIA was all about what
the origins of the show was all about
and what the intelligence community's
purpose is and and what has been a very
trying time for this country
particularly in the past three years
where intelligence has been at war with
the administration and Mandy were you
ready when we talked to Claire Danes
when she was here when we were back in
the studio it's clear that the two of
you have a very special bond I'm
wondering were you ready and what your
final scene was like I would think that
would have been tough it was very tough
I wasn't ready for it at all we as you
will see this coming Sunday night it's
some of the most intense stuff we have
ever been engaged in and all of a sudden
we finished the scene and a voice came
out of the room saying ladies and
gentlemen that was the last shot between
Carrie Mathison and Saul Berenson of
homeland and it was like a shocking
moment and then we found each other's
eyes and we fell into each others arms
and we began to feel our bodies shake as
we were both mutually weeping and
holding on to each other for dear life
and just dealing with we started this in
2010 so it was virtually ten years of
our lives and trying to grapple with
what that means that one minute a switch
is pulled and or flicked and and it's
over Wow I can only imagine you know
Mandy I'm curious you've said something
interesting about your character Saul
Berenson you said a lot of things
interesting about him but one thing in
particular so stuck out could be a
spin-off episode here you say he made
you a better husband and a better man
Saul Berenson merits counselor better
man camp how did he do that he it was it
was just good luck on a lot of levels
the writers wrote a character who was
very quiet and calm different from my
own personal nature he was a better list
than I ever was he was a kinder gentler
human being than I was and a a more
empathic human being than I was although
I feel I had some of those qualities and
a combination of that situation and
being with Claire and our writers and
and time gave my wife and my two
children a husband that was a little bit
more like Saul than like Mandy and they
liked that and so he will go with me
wherever I go for the rest of my life
that that better listener quiet more
empathic human being who at times loses
it and has to make some pretty brutal
decisions and choices but that's how
life is for most of us Mandy that's a
beautiful sentiment thank you very much
and thank you for giving us so many
hours with this show so many hours away
from ourselves we could use that from
time to time and away from the world as
it is